so I wasn't really expecting to talk
about the Bourne Legacy trailer because
I actually didn't know was coming out
the same with the spider-man trailer
it's weird that all these big trailers
have come up lately I'm a big fan of the
Bourne trilogy it really propelled Matt
Damon into stardom
they were great action films I really
think that the Bourne Ultimatum is one
of the best action films ever made and
for a while they were playing I'm making
a Bourne for and then they just kind of
trickled down and it wasn't really gonna
happen no one I heard about the Bourne
Legacy and then it was gonna be Jeremy
Renner who I really like I was really
worried at first because I was like it's
are they gonna replace the Bourne
character I don't know if that'll work I
don't really feel like the Bourne
character is a it's like a bond like
character where you can continuously
replace them with a different actor but
then I heard they were going in a
different direction and telling a
different story within the same universe
and that is really cool to me because
not only is that a lucrative idea from a
financial standpoint and I'm sure
Studios like that but it's a good way to
keep the story in a safe place without
doing any harm to the previous films and
I really like this trailer
welcome to the program
seeing jeremy renner standing before
albert finney of the beat up face and
albert finney with his creepy way of
saying welcome to the program and then
edward norton is talking to him and
edward norton is just awesome and
whenever he's involved the project
automatically kind of legitimacy is it
it's makes it better like Oh Edward
Norton's in it okay that changes things
that makes things different there is
nothing that you wouldn't do for this
country you and the strength to do
what's necessary it's written and
directed by Tony Gilroy he had a lot of
involvement with the previous Bourne
films it looks like it's a very similar
style of filmmaking the other thing I
really like it when the trailer was the
first half of it had those bars going
back and forth altering the images and I
would just like to have seen the shots
just how they are in the movie but that
that's nothing really I mean it's just a
teaser trailer I really like this
trailer I think the movie looks good I
think Jeremy Renner looks good what do
you guys think the Bourne Legacy how do
you feel about this this kind of
revamping of the of the plot at least
it's not like a taking over the
character I'm very pleased with that
but if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes